en un día típico de escuela se pierden
interminables horas aprendiendo a
responder preguntas
pero justo ahora haremos lo contrario
nos centraremos en preguntas de las que
no hay respuestas por aprender porque se
desconoce
cuándo niño solía interrogarme sobre
muchas cosas por ejemplo
que se sentiría siendo un perro sienten
dolor los peces que hay de los insectos
fue el 'big bang' sólo un accidente
existe un dios de ser así como
aseguramos que es él y no ella porque
tanta gente inocente y animales sufren
cosas terribles en verdad hay un plan
trazado de mi vida está por escribirse
el futuro ya está escrito solo que no
podemos verlo pero si tengo libre
albedrío es decir quién soy a fin de
cuentas acaso soy una máquina biológica
entonces porque soy consciente que es la
conciencia serán los robots conscientes
algún día quiero suponer que algún día
me dirán las respuestas a todas estas
preguntas
alguien debe saberlas no
pues que creen nadie sabe la mayoría de
estas preguntas me confunden ahora más
que nunca pero bucear en ellas es
emocionante porque te llevan a la
frontera del conocimiento y nunca sabes
que hallarás ahí entonces dos preguntas
preguntas que nadie en la tierra tiene
la respuesta
a veces cuando voy en un largo viaje de
avión miró fijamente esas montañas y
desiertos e intento meter en mi cabeza
la vastedad de la tierra entonces
recuerdo que hay un objeto que a diario
vemos en el que cabría un millón de
tierras enteras el sol que parece
imposible mente grande pero en el gran
esquema de cosas es una insignificancia
una de casi 400.000 millones de
estrellas de la vía láctea que puedes
ver en una noche clara como una pálida
neblina blanca extendida en el cielo y
se pone peor quizás hay 100.000 millones
de galaxias detectables por nuestros
telescopios si cada estrella fuera del
tamaño de un grano de arena tan solo la
vía láctea tendría suficientes para
llenar una playa de 10 x 10 metros por
un metro de profundidad de arena
la tierra entera no tiene playas
suficientes para representar las
estrellas de todo el universo una playa
así se extendería por cientos de
millones de kilómetros bendito stephen
hopkins eso es un montón de estrellas
pero él y otros físicos ahora creen en
una realidad que es inconcebible mente
más grande todavía es decir primero que
nada que las 100 mil millones de
galaxias al alcance de nuestros
telescopios son probablemente una
fracción minúscula del total el espacio
mismo se está expandiendo a paso
acelerado la vasta mayoría de las
galaxias se separan de nosotros tan
rápido que su luz quizás nunca nos
alcance aún así nuestra realidad física
aquí en la tierra está íntimamente
conectada con esas galaxias invisibles
podemos pensar en ellas como partes de
nuestro universo constituye en un
gigante edificio que obedece las mismas
leyes físicas con los mismos átomos
electrones protones quarks neutrinos eso
de lo que estamos hechos tú y yo sin
embargo recientes teorías de la física
también la llamada teoría de cuerdas nos
dicen que podría haber infinidad de
otros universos compuestos de tipos de
partículas diferentes que obedecen a
leyes diferentes la mayoría de estos
universos no podrían sustentar nunca la
vida y podrían existir en un abrir y
cerrar de un nanosegundo aún así
combinado forman un vasto multiverso de
posibles universos de hasta 11
dimensiones que presentan maravillas más
allá de nuestra más desbocada
imaginación la versión imperante de la
teoría de cuerdas predice un multiverso
formado de 10 a 500 universos esto es
uno seguido de 500 0 un número tan vasto
que se cada átomo en nuestro universo
observable tuviera su propio universo y
todos los átomos en todos esos universos
tuvieran cada uno de sus propios
universos y repitiéramos esto por dos
ciclos más tendríamos todavía una
diminuta fracción del total esto es 14
veces un trillón uno seguido de 18 ceros
de un trillones simó
pero incluso este número es diminuto
comparado con otro número infinito
algunos físicos piensan que el
espacio-tiempo continuo es cabalmente
infinito que contiene un número infinito
de los llamados universos de bolsillo
con propiedades variadas como está tu
cerebro la teoría cuántica agrega una
arruga entera más esto es la teoría ha
sido probada más allá de toda duda pero
su interpretación es inquietante y
algunos físicos piensan que para poder
apaciguar nos si imaginamos que ese
enorme número de universos paralelos se
está propagando a cada momento y muchos
de estos universos serían en efecto muy
parecidos a nuestro mundo e incluirían
múltiples copias de uno en uno de tales
universos te graduaría con honores y te
casarías con la persona de tus sueños en
otro no tanto así todavía hay algunos
científicos que dirían disparates la
única respuesta significativa a la
pregunta de cuántos universos existen es
uno solo un universo algunos cuantos
filósofos y místicos discutirían que
incluso nuestro propio universo es una
ilusión
entonces como puedes ver mismo no hay
consenso en esta pregunta ni de cerca
todo lo que sabemos es que la respuesta
estaba en algún lugar entre cero e
infinito creo que sabemos algo más
estamos en una era de lo más fabulosa
para estudiar física quizás estamos
experimentando el cambio de paradigma
más grande del conocimiento que la
humanidad haya visto
en algún lugar allá afuera en el vasto
universo seguramente infinidad de otros
planetas repletos de vida pero porque no
vemos evidencia de ello bueno esta es la
famosa pregunta hecha por enrico fermi
en 1950 donde están todos teorías
conspirativas afirman que los ovnis nos
visitan a cada rato y los informes
simplemente se ocultan pero honestamente
no son nada convincentes pero eso deja
un acertijo real el año pasado el
observatorio espacial kepler encontró
cientos de planetas cerca de estrellas
cercanas se extrapolan en sus datos
parece que podría haber un mil millones
de planetas en nuestra propia galaxia si
una en 10.000 tiene condiciones que
pudieran superar una forma de vida eso
es además 50 millones de posibles
planetas que albergan vida justo aquí en
la vía láctea aquí el acertijo nuestra
tierra no se formó hasta pasado cerca de
9 mil millones de años atrás el 'big
bang' infinidad de otros planetas en
nuestra galaxia debieron haberse formado
mucho antes dando ocasión a la creación
de vida miles de millones o siete muchos
millones de años antes de que ocurriera
en la tierra si solo en unos cuantos de
ellos se propagó vida inteligente y
empezaron a crear tecnologías esas
tecnologías habrían tenido millones de
años para crecer en complejidad y poder
en la tierra hemos visto la drástica
aceleración que puede lograr la
tecnología en sólo 100 años en millones
de años una civilización alienígena
inteligente podría fácilmente haberse
diseminado por la galaxia quizás creando
artefactos recolectores de energía o
flotas de naves colonizadoras obras de
arte gloriosas que inundan el cielo
nocturno
al menos pensaríamos que nos revelaría
en su presencia deliberadamente o no
mediante sus señales electromagnéticas
de algún tipo u otro y aún no vemos
evidencia convincente de ello por qué
bueno existen numerosas respuestas
posibles algunas muy oscuras
quizá una sola civilización super
inteligente ha tomado en efecto la
galaxia y ha impuesto un estricto
silencio radial porque tiene paranoia de
competidores potenciales
está sentado ahí listo para anular
cualquier cosa que sea una amenaza
o quizás no existe esa inteligencia o
quizá la evolución de una inteligencia
capaz de crear tecnologías sofisticadas
es mucho más raras de lo que suponemos
después de todo sólo ocurrió una vez en
la tierra hace cuatro mil millones de
años
quizá incluso eso fue increíblemente
fortuito
quizás somos la primera civilización en
nuestra galaxia o quizás la civilización
porta consigo las semillas de su propia
destrucción en su incapacidad de
controlar las tecnologías que crean
pero hay numerosas respuestas más
prometedoras primero nos buscamos con
ahínco y gastamos una cantidad irrisoria
de dinero solo una diminuta fracción de
estrellas en nuestra galaxia ha sido
vistas de cerca en busca de señales
interesantes y quizás no buscamos en el
camino correcto quizás cuando las
civilizaciones se desarrollaron pronto
descubrieron tecnologías de comunicación
mucho más sofisticadas y útiles que las
ondas electromagnéticas
quizás toda la acción ocurre dentro de
la misteriosa y recientemente
descubierta materia oscura o energía
oscura que parece construir más de la
masa del universo
o quizá miramos con la escala incorrecta
quizás las civilizaciones inteligentes
se dieron cuenta que la vida en el fondo
solo son patrones complejos de
información que interactúan bellamente
entre sí y que eso puede suceder con más
eficiencia a pequeña escala así como en
la tierra los voluminosos sistemas de
stereo se encogieron en bellos y
pequeños botes quizás la inteligencia
misma para reducir su huella de carbono
en el ambiente se volvió a microscópica
el sistema solar podría estar repleto de
alienígenas y simplemente no lo notamos
quizás las ideas mismas en nuestras
cabezas son una forma de vida alienígena
bueno de acuerdo esa es una idea loca
los alienígenas me hicieron decirlo pero
es fabuloso pensar que las ideas
parezcan tener una vida propia y que
trasciendan a sus creadores quizás la
vida biológica es sólo una fase de
tránsito bueno dentro de los próximos 15
años podríamos empezar a ver información
espectroscópicas real de planetas
cercanos que prometan revelar lo amables
que podrían ser
mientras tanto setting está publicando
sus datos para que millones de
ciudadanos científicos quizás tú
incluido puedan unir el poder de las
masas en la búsqueda
y aquí en la tierra experimentos
asombrosos intentan crear vida de cero
vida que podría ser diferente a las
formas de adn que conocemos todo esto
nos servirá para entender si el universo
está repleto de vida o si en efecto solo
somos nosotros
cuál sea la respuesta a su manera es
impresionante porque aunque estuviéramos
solos el hecho de que pensamos que
soñamos y hacemos estas preguntas podría
convertirse en uno de los hechos más
importantes del universo y tengo una
buena noticia más que dar la búsqueda de
conocimiento y entendimiento nunca será
aburrida no lo es sino todo lo contrario
cuanto más sabes más asombroso parece el
mundo y son las locas posibilidades las
preguntas sin respuestas que nos empujan
a avanzar que tu curiosidad persista